hey youtubers surprise surprise special
Game of Thrones video today just because
they announced details for the
behind-the-scenes special they're going
to be airing just like last year it's
gonna be like the foreshadowing special
they aired last year but it'll be like a
full half hour they do have like there
are three big locations belfast northern
ireland dubrovnik and split in croatia
Sevilla and asuna and Spain but then you
know for specific scenes they will go to
the smaller places like Costel since
this is a special that they'll be airing
on HBO before the season I don't expect
them to go to any super spoilery places
like the scenes that they do show for
mine the scenes will be fairly general I
will do a full breakdown whenever the
special airs so we can talk about the
scenes that we think that they're
filming there's always like a fine line
I try to draw when when talking about
behind-the-scenes stuff because I can
actually do videos like this while
they're filming because there are always
a lot of pictures from the set the
problem is is it like you know half the
people don't want to talk about it hath
people do so I always try to like walk
the line the best thing you guys can do
whenever we do videos like this is just
tell me like what specifically do you
want to talk about the most like do you
care about the scenes they might be
filming or do you want to talk about
something completely different so as
much feedback as possible always
appreciate it thank you very much just
to give you an idea for what the
specials going to look like it as a
reminder here's the special from last
year again so just watch that again it's
going to look a lot like this it'll
bounce back and forth between interviews
with the cast and behind-the-scenes
stuff but they will be talking to the
crew a lot just because they'll be
talking about filming the actual
episodes
if I went to sleep for a year when I
woke up the world's falling apart there
is tremendous clamor for revenge
especially in the wake of the red
wedding captain Stark's death Richard
Madden and in a chaplain that moment I
knew it was coming and it kill it ripped
me up inside I cried I actually shared
it to you that yeah a tattooed all the
performances were or extraordinary and
it was very emotional to do it's sort of
where do you go from there some of the
most shocking and mind-blowing scenes of
the entire series come the end of this
coming season some very bloody
confrontations I know how important the
red wedding is to so many fans of the
show and the books but we pick up the
pieces and top it in many ways this is
definitely the most dangerous season for
Tyrion it seems like almost every
episode he's in jeopardy of getting his
head removed from his shoulders Tyrion
has never been faced with this much
public humiliation because he usually
has an answer for it I've talked myself
out of a thousand all corners pulled
reckon don't think I'm talking my way
out of this one he's usually center
stage and usually is better at it than
the people around him this time around
he's left as a an audience member I'm
guilty being a dwarf
there's no boundary with her interior of
inflicting emotional damage she's quite
happy to do it you've always pitied him
oh poor little brother he'd kill us all
if he could Tyrion and Jaime definitely
have a love that Tyrion doesn't have
with the other members of his family and
he helps Tyrion great deal this season
yeah the last friend you've got a royal
wedding is history time has come for us
all to contemplate our history in terms
of the challenge of the wedding it's the
entirety of it it's the totality of
massive team which takes up about half
the episode it was like shooting a short
film in itself actually I was shocked by
the sheer scale I really have never seen
anything like that in Game of Thrones
before I would find it very hard that I
would have a wedding ceremony replicated
like that again in my career it was
majestic it was shimmering
just look pristine I think that's a what
Jeffrey likes he likes he has something
ostentatious and grand
the great thing about this show is they
like to put you into atmospheres and
into environments that conjure up
certain feelings inside of you when you
plan the scenes out your imagination is
kind of fueled it's all there my throne
room is a mini tropical version of a
Westeros throne room that set is
unbelievable I walked in and was like
open mouth for a good 10 minutes very
intimidating and Amelia's love me what
kind of look up at him in this kind of
frightened me she's exploring what kind
of a leader she could be how can I rule
Seven Kingdoms if I can't control a
single city the cities that danny has
previously liberated are beginning to
revolt because it's all well and good
going in and cutting the tie and
seemingly breaking people free but if
you don't leave them with any kind of a
structure or any kind of a commander who
shares the same morals and views as the
person who liberated them then it's a
free-for-all they can live in my new
world or they can die in their old one
when the dragons were first born and
they were adorable little babies and and
I completely devoted to their mother and
they couldn't even eat without her the
gate season they grow and he cheese and
they become a little bit more dangerous
and now they're at the point where
they're not babies anymore they are out
growing the restrictions that she's
placing on them she's always feared it I
mean for goodness sake they're dragons
they've killed her enemies what's gonna
stop him from killing anyone his their
dragons in a in a non dragon world
they're dragons Khaleesi they could
never be tamed I think it's kind of a
symbol of her losing control of herself
and losing control of what she's doing
the thing that I got most excited about
is John is not the same man from season
to season there's too much that's
happened to him too much that's gone on
and that he's had to learn from we find
him in season four he's in a very bad
place as far as how he feels he treated
he groupement his honor because of now
not only breaking his vows to the Nights
wat for breaking his vows to her he's in
a lose-lose position really but he has
to make good you've done nothing wrong
done plenty wrong he's reunited with Sam
which is a good thing but their
relationships changed salmon John's
relationship this year is as even and
equal as it's ever been there's more
confrontation between them this season
you're waddling girl she's one of the
Raiders not my girl yeah but she was
wasn't she it's a very different
relationship we find themselves in but
still a loving ones to look caring one
and I think without Sam John would
crumble
oh that's an easy one involves
prosthetics well big man oh I can find
your clothes Idol one of the most
terrifying things I've ever had to do
where's the opening shot of season three
they work to get this feeling of
something being behind sound something
in pursuit of Sam so they decided the
only way to achieve that effect was to
chase me on a quad bike through the snow
and they are the guy running alongside
so the reason I'm here is if you fall
over I'll get the quad bike to stop
haven't thanks very much they don't know
what they paying you but it's not enough
sometimes greeting CGI wolves is a
strange experience this big green
sausage dummy shoved in your face and
you have to treat it as if it's your
lifelong pattern love it to bits is very
odd the most weird thing I've had to do
this season is to bite off a man's air
get it in his face sure someone walks
into the castle black say I thought oh
my god because until you step into it
physically when it comes out of your
head and into the real world it sends
chills down your spine wood chopping off
Theon Greyjoy's companion was probably
quite chief no red light oh really every
day on this show is an OMG moment really
because there's always surprises and it
you're always in a really cool location
or you've got great crop oh you know the
set is incredible the thing is amazing
about the places we shoot is you just
don't know what to expect see turn up
and you're like wow this is
much grander than I could have expected
or could have ever imagined his OMG
moment is when you think you nearly
finished and then you've got five hours
to go well nickel iono tried to do a
dance number walking down the steps of
the court we thought it was fun and the
extras was all laughing and dancing but
the crew was really tired I don't think
they responded and they were just heard
from the ad like still rolling reset
whenever maisie's around there's usually
a lot of sleepovers and like we do a lot
of knock and runs on people's hotel
balls you know you'd see Dame Diana Rigg
playing playing backgammon with daniel
portman and see Lena giving massage to
someone and everyone's just chatting and
joking around and that's a really nice
moment everyone else gets the badass
quotes I think the best quotes of bronze
quotes any line he has witty and
intelligent and hilarious you don't
fight with honor he says no he did
hmm ok well there without saying where
he said Hodor Hodor Hodor Hodor that was
definitely a badass one I think it would
be when egrets head is on that rock
strike hard and true Jon Snow I'll come
back and haunt you oh that's a great
time well there's one this year when
she's talking about nothing maybe
nothing is worse than this nothing isn't
better for worse than anything nothing
is just nothing I think that makes you
really think about all the different
characters and you kind of puts things
into perspective Oh trick Horace
dracarys definitely I believe that's
probably the most badass quake I think
as in previous seasons there's a build I
think what makes the season different is
that things really get going much more
quickly it's more thrilling throughout
then season 3 was
there's definitely objectively more
action than there are a whole lot of
things on the production front that
we've never done before everyone's kind
of now loading the guns loading the
arrows sharpening their knives and it's
just right it's not building towards one
specific climactic event there are more
climactic events in season 4 than there
have ever been before every season up
until now has been episode 9 has been
the big episode season four is just very
steady the stakes are higher throughout
the season and they happen before this
season the story just gets more intense
some really juicy mental storylines is
just really exciting the buttons pressed
and the accelerator is firmly to the
floor here and there's a lot of action
the good guys are coming back this year
and that's nice to see yeah we're making
stand we hope people when they come out
of the season what will feel that the
impact of the season as a whole would be
even greater than the impact of the
previous season there are so many
quality shows on television that I love
and admire but I don't think there's one
with the scale that game of thrones in
terms of the size of the cast in terms
of
our country as we shoot in and pina who
else has dragons really
so just like I said yesterday in my
man's video my next bonus video is going
to be a character video but then they'll
probably be posting the trailer like
right after that so the video like after
that will be the trailer so be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you have
any special requests for bonus videos
let me know and right now while you wait
you can click here if you haven't seen
it this is the man's video and you can
click here to learn all about Kai burn
thank you so much for watching let's all
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you